يبدو محمد ابو اللد للوهله الاولى كغيره
من العمال الاتراك الذين يعملون في مواقع
البناء فابو اللد لاجئ سوري هرب الى تركيا
مع عائلته بعد مشاركته في الاحتجاجات
المناهضه للاسد منذ ما يقرب السته اشهر
طبعا هي النظام لا محاله لان الشعب كله
انتف لا محاله هو رايح
لاني فاتوره الدم صارت فاتوره
كبيره ويقول ابو انه يعمل بطريقه غير
قانونيه معتمدا على اي عمل يدوي وذلك
ليستطيع تغطيه نفقات اسرته لا توجد
احصاءات مؤكده حول اعداد اللاجئين
السوريين المقيمين في تركيا فبعض النازحين
هنا انتهت صلاحيه تاشيرات ويعيشون الان
بشكل غير قانوني في البلاد نلعب لعبه القط
والفقر يعني مع البوليس التركي هيدي مشكله
اولادنا متعطلين من اشهر عن المدارس نحن
ما عم نشتغل شي ما فينا عم نعمل
شي ويخش معظم سكان المخيمات من النيران
التي تطلقها القوات السوريه على الحدود
نحن الش بدنا فيها يكون ح نحن بطلب حمايه
دوليه للشعب وتدخل عسكري ما مريد بس بدنا
حمايه دوليه ويحاول السوريون هنا التكيف
مع الاوضاع المعيشيه الصعبه في انتظار
الخلاص